réservez vos places dès maintenant pour
découvrir tout son sel en avant-première
en famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la la la bonté près mon grand ja je suis
prêt de chez près chaque habitant de
cette ville a une chance de devenir une
star grâce à notre concours de chant
vous allez être ébouriffés par le pi 10
po
[Musique]
ça va très bien merci
fo si vous voulez devenir des stars et
gagner 100 mille dollars
vous allez devoir travailler plus dur
que vous ne l'avez jamais fait toute
votre vie
oui c'était très mauvais ou et chauny il
est pas là
ouais ce que tu étais c'était une
répétition papa je veux pas faire partie
de son gang
ce que je veux c'est être chanteur
comment j'ai fait pour avoir un fils
comme toi font sans tennis et tennis
chez du toit contre trois que je peux y
arriver oui ou non cela qu'est ce qui se
passe ici
il faut jamais laisser la peur nous
empêcher de faire ce qu'on aime c'est
est ce qu'il a bien quand on a touché le
fond c'est qu'il ne reste plus qu'une
issue on doit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selmon ce piston
elle est hyper nu celle là ouais non
c'est clair je peux pas bouger
terrorisés
allez chante
[Musique]
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas répéter cette
fois c'est moi ils m'ont carrément
accusé d'être égocentrique
je sais même pas ce que ça veut dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]